hello and thank you for joining us today
for the webinar titled data privacy and
other clinical data management
challenges I'm Sonali Paul CEO at cloud
lems calm I'm here to moderate this
event
Marian Henderson is joining us today as
the presenter she's the senior adviser
on bio banking to the NCA Center for
Global Health and the senior advisor for
division resources dceg she's a founding
member of the NCI biospecimen
Coordinating Committee established by
the NCI biorepositories and biospecimen
research branch and participated in the
development and revision of the first
and second edition of nci's best
practices for biospecimen resources
since 1999 she has been a member of is
bur and served as the Easter president
2011-12 Marianne is currently the chair
of the izba organising advisory
committee for more details please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen Marion I would like to extend a
warm welcome to you before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click send we will take as many
questions as time permits due to time
constraints if you are unable to answer
your question today we will answer them
offline if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen it is time now to hand over
the floor to Marion
it is over to you hello I'm Mary Ann
Henderson and I work at the US National
Cancer Institute I'm glad you're
accessing this webinar on data privacy
and other clinical management challenges
today we'll focus on several areas why
laboratory data management is important
regulations and guidelines around data
management data management challenges
for clinical research laboratories and
tools and tactics for privacy and
security management of data and research
is in the spotlight there's an emphasis
on high quality meaning minimizing
errors and missing data while maximizing
the data generated in the lab laboratory
data should be available to be shared
both in the context of interoperability
and regulatory compliance the goal is
being able to combine and use data to
affect clinical care in the future
proper data management is important
doing it well is expensive the cost of
doing it loosely is high almost daily we
hear that the latest database hack with
banking your credit card or maybe Social
Security numbers being vulnerable and in
the hands of hackers increasingly
laboratory equipment is networked and
workstations are linked to the internet
bringing more security threat there's a
demand now for continuous security
monitoring to keep data safe laboratory
managers need to be knowledgeable about
security threats and privacy regulations
that impact their clinical research
laboratory and you should be aware of
the technological solutions that address
security and privacy threats to your
data systems there should you should
have a plan
to guard against threats whether their
intrusions environmental disasters or
human errors there are many regulations
and guidelines that govern the
management of data how its collected and
controlled
stored shared and potentially destroyed
here are some US examples we won't
really have time to go through them
specifically but feel free to look them
up because we're in an era of data
sharing and the need to combine datasets
from other areas of the world you must
also understand the regulations and
guidelines in those parts of the world
here are some examples of regulations
and guidelines for privacy and data
security and human subjects safety in
Europe well I don't think most
laboratory scientists see themselves as
informatics experts unfortunately we
can't just stick our heads in the sand
focusing in on data management
challenges within the clinical
laboratory there are several
considerations providing accurate and
timely data if assays are performed in
several locations there also must be a
harmonization of processes so that data
is comparable and reproducible accurate
and valid data enhances specimen
analysis and interpretation accurate
data produced from fewer rounds of
testing also reduces costs in turn
harmonized laboratory operations
following industry best practices to
produce accurate data is more cost
effective and efficient expanding the
influence of staff through such
successful patient care or research
finding
the opportunity is how to manage all of
these challenges with the mind toward
securely protecting the data being
produced by your laboratory as a Data
Manager for a clinical lab these are
tasks you must manage managing massive
amounts of data generated from the
laboratory sharing your data with other
systems or other databases inside and
outside of your organization compliance
with regulatory and privacy demands with
traceability ethical and cultural
protections for the patients or
participants private information and
real-time tracking of results being
produced in your laboratory or your
organization is there really a threat to
poor data management well here are two
examples that say yes these are examples
of breached data systems malicious or
not it was the result of poor data
management and protection each of these
for expensive defects and allowed the
private data for millions of patients to
be exposed outside of their healthcare
systems these breaches also damaged the
reputation of the organization's
to summarize there are several areas to
consider in data management from
understanding and complying with
regulations to protecting privacy and
data security to integrating data
throughout your systems and data
analytics and resources these are a lot
to consider so what can be done so
here's some tools and tactics for
privacy and security let's talk about
solutions there are laboratory
information systems to safely management
manage laboratory data they come in many
varieties some are developed in-house
with expertise some are open source and
some are commercially available to set
up and go to make the right decision to
cover your needs for a system your needs
must be assessed in several ways we'll
go through these items later in the talk
but they include a privacy impact
assessment or a key ia privacy
engineering operations assessment as
well as learning from others whatever
system you choose to evaluate for your
needs you need to make sure that that
vendor or that developer demonstrates
how the system effectively handles the
security and privacy of your data also
where will the data be stored will it be
stored locally or will it be stored in
the cloud more and more systems and
tools and data are being stored and
aggregated in the cloud as we're moving
into the era of big
data if choosing a vendor offering a
cloud-based solution make sure to
understand their data security
operations auditing practices and access
control some considerations for data
security in the cloud include how our
users identified and authenticated and
how our users kept out what access
controls are in place and who can have
access how does the security policy
protect against malware how a software
distributed what systems controls are
implemented how is the data backed up
and what happens if there's an incident
a laboratory informatics solution should
help you achieve data privacy and
security through role based access
through audit logs through password
controls through session management
through encryption and backup protocols
and intrusion and malware detection
mechanisms now we'll talk about more of
the assessment tools a privacy impact
assessment or P ia must be carried out
on a system to determine whether the
data being collected complies with
privacy related legal and regulatory
requirements and look at your scope
definition of all the activities that
you're doing it analyzed the flow of
data from one point to the endpoint and
they analyze the privacy implications of
your activity and proposed system and
they document the assessment steps to
with risk mitigation P IAS are very
commonplace in in data systems and
shouldn't be ignored privacy engineering
is an emerging discipline within the
software and Information Systems domain
it aims to provide methodology tools and
techniques such as engineering systems
that provide acceptable levels of
privacy
starting with foundational privacy
principles they look into the process
management and governance of that
activity and the tools and techniques
and ontology
as well being used an Operations
assessment is an evaluation of the
effectiveness and suitability of a
system a fit for purpose evaluation of
the adequacy and reliability of the
system for its intended operations is
your whole organization operations setup
for safeguarding the data you're
collecting the results of this
assessment may require somewhat drastic
measures for mitigation such as business
reengineering organizational realignment
significant management commitment these
are not cheap to do if you have or not
setup for privacy and keeping private
data and development of new or revised
these procedures
as well as painful as it can be you can
learn from others mistakes so that you
don't repeat them here are some not to
be repeated you don't want to fail to
train employees on privacy and security
issues and procedures you don't want to
fail to get approval for systems to be
launched in your network or organization
don't miss configure to produce data and
system owner abilities open doors for
hackers and failing to set up and in
place procedures and policies for
privacy and security in your
organization these are all definite
knows so in this webinar we covered why
you need to focus on laboratory data
management to be more productive to use
data to gain insights to manage data in
a safe and productive way to do it
according to regulations and to manage
the four or five V's of data these are
volume variety veracity or
trustworthiness you definitely want to
have your data trusted and velocity the
processing frequency and value there
will be where where your data lead you
in discovery or clinical care in the
future the various regulations and
guidelines you need to be aware of for
specific data management activities were
covered and the challenges associated
with clinical and research laboratory
data management and lastly the tools and
tactics for privacy and security with
steps to assess your current operations
while modifying them to meet your
privacy needs for your data
thank you now we can take a few
questions Thank You Marion for the
presentation we are now ready to begin
answering the questions submitted during
today's presentation as a reminder you
can still submit questions through the
chat box will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for we have a
number of interesting questions so I
will move straight into these the first
question is what are your
recommendations for improving data
quality my recommendation to improve
data quality is to first focus on good
study design for the research questions
that are to be answered by the study
strong study design and the appropriate
data analysis are very important
components to achieving and improving
data quality ensuring effective data
management is also essential to accurate
data collection entry reports and
validation could you elaborate some of
the best practices for clinical data
management clinical data management is
complex and an ever-changing landscape
and three best practices in this area
include knowing where your data is
coming from the types of data and the
people responsible for the data that you
are managing develop a robust data
management plan to delineate governance
of the data who is the owner and who can
provide access to the data depending on
the data access may be regulated by
HIPAA or high tech privacy and security
requirements knowing how long the data
can be stored if that is regulated is
also important if you have several
systems that are providing data in your
organization it is important to find a
solution to connect the disparate silos
of data to get the most value from it
there are many more operational best
practices but these are a few of the
most important
how do you define high quality data in
which ways can it be achieved
data is high-quality if it's it is fit
for its intended uses in operations
decision-making and planning
alternatively data is deemed of high
quality if it correctly represents the
real-world construct to which it refers
I previously mentioned ways to improve
data quality usually data gets lost sand
silos how should organizations address
this issue organizations should attempt
to connect their silos of data to
maximize their use by enabling
interoperability between their systems
some organizations have done this to
creating central data repositories while
others have created federated systems
that can be queried across them the
systems the advent of EU GDP are what
are the implications for informed
consent and maintaining data the EU GDP
are is focused on the personal privacy
of data emanating from persons in the
European Economic Area
this regulation governs the transfer and
use of that data within and outside of
the EEA currently the territorial reach
of the EU GDP are is being clarified
especially in terms of international
research and data sharing outside of the
EU I am sure we will hear more and
understand more about the implications
for for informed consent and maintaining
data associated with the EEA
how should organizations address missing
data I am no expert in this area of
missing data but there are a few general
ways that I could point to it could be
that the participant or patient with
missing values is deleted from the final
analysis data set
if there is a way to recover the values
that are missing from a participant or
patient maybe that is an option maybe
recontacting or maybe there are also
ways to impute or substitute the missing
values this is definitely the most I
know in this area and should be
discussed with a biostatistician
unfortunately the time is up for today
before we go I would like to thank you
for joining us questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
answered via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
the next six months lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event the
webinar recording will be uploaded on
the cloud limbs website as well have a
great day ahead and thank you